the Joe Rogan experience no I host this
show
is he always like this always oh no
people nope I got friends who asked me
so your dad just that's who he is or
that does is that a character I'm like
oh no no he got on for being himself
yeah yeah I told him that jokingly I was
like you know you left you right he's
like what you mean like you are you're
where you are cuz you are who you are
you you don't have to fake it you just
know you funny enough you definitely do
yourself yeah I'm on the cartoon what
did the boondocks mmm uh-huh they hadn't
changed my voice for the boondocks no I
did all I did that and they coming back
become a balloon I was coming back
that's a great show yeah one of the best
cartoons
I met the dude who created he was
friends of my friend Todd yeah smart
dude yeah Jesus yeah that's another one
that you're on that you had like that he
like fell into that's the funny part
because because remember what the thing
is I went in for that show to play one
of the one of the leads or whatever it
didn't happen but I remember cuz he's
you know he's friends with Aaron and
whatnot Aaron just called him in to do a
like a one day roll remember we need
your character to to just do the pilot
know Jesus I'm a homeless man so I got
into I thought it was cool yeah you want
the job is yours good so he went in to
do like a like a guest star role and
then they were like dang he's funnier
than then what we were thinking so we so
they gave him a role and that he was the
series right you did three season we you
did - they did a third one that it
hasn't aired yet and I use see when I
did Hollywood shuffle I hate I played a
man who had lost everything he was
hungry so I'm sitting out there and
Robert Townsend didn't have any money
for wardrobe so I went at the
second-hand store good wheeled and
bought coveralls and old shirt and I had
a t-shirt that I tore and put a pen to
put it back up so that was I thought
that was clever
and so this happened 20 years ago I kept
that outfit in my garage for 20 years
and I used it on black Jesus same thing
I wore no Hollywood shuffle shuffle what
was it
hokey what's the name in it Hollywood
shuffle that's a shelf do you there it
is yeah but then they said yes so then
they took so then he wore it they they
did they thing and then they were like
well this thing's stinks so we'll just
recreate it for you they did everything
over it got the same outfit that I had
my little wine there okay so whatever
happened at Robert Townsend ways he up
to
he's a director now just directing
different movies not a different movie
and commercials and things he's do stand
up to oh yeah we on tour with him we
worked all the big polices I remember
his specials yeah he always had those uh
HBO comedy special yeah oh yeah and
Wayans did um yeah yeah did him yeah
Robert Townes he's still around I saw
the picture no my phone I don't know how
I don't know it's probably a new jacket
man
[Applause]